President Vladimir zielinski arrives at
the G7 Summit and the world it seems
stops to watch at the international
Media Center crowds gather around the
monitors for a glimpse of the Ukrainian
leader arriving on a plane provided to
him by France but the planes he's most
interested in now are F-16 fighter jets
after a decision by the U.S finally to
allow their delivery to Ukraine we've
reached a moment where it is time to
look down the road and to say what is
Ukraine going to need as part of a
future force to be able to deter and
defend against Russian aggression as we
go forward f-16's fourth generation
fighter aircraft are part of that mix
this second day of the G7 has been
focused on a range of themes from the
global economy to The Climate crisis
we're launching a new joint initiative
to accelerate a transition to clean
energy
including by building more resilient
critical mineral Supply chains there
have been expanded sessions for invited
world leaders including those from the
poorer countries of the so-called Global
South that richer Nations have often
been accused of ignoring
in welcoming guest world leaders
Japanese prime minister fumio kishida
recognized the complex problems facing
the world they are crises that have been
worsened by the Ukraine war that
according to its critics the G7 is
failing to address if the G7 wants
support for the war in Ukraine from the
global South then it's in their interest
to cancel debts to put more money on the
table for food to show that they
understand the kind of Ripple effects of
the Ukraine conflict on the poorest
people the extended guest list includes
many neutral world leaders whom zelenski
would like to win over to his cause but
the visit also gives him more in-person
time with the G7 leaders who so far have
been his biggest backers to accommodate
zielinski's presence the final day of
this G7 Summit is being extended
illustrating his Global stature the
chance to be fated by the world's
richest and most powerful Nations is a
major victory for him and another likely
source of resentment for an excluded
Russia Rob McBride Al Jazeera Hiroshima
Japan